I've decided to get the horrible blocker treatment that my oncologist suggested in order to try and aggressively shake my ear positive breast to this.
In my mind, while the estrogen is blocked, I want to double down and they program to kill the cancer.
My goal is to have no cancer left to cut out.
I don't know if this is realistic but I like to try at least and at the very least have a less involved surgery.
I think you just got to keep a very positive mindset that it gets a great goal to have.
I'm supposed to start two injections in a pill I'm fighting.
At what point in my treatment should I send a cheek swab to get the next phase going strong?
I'd wait until you know after your take this for after you're on the injection probably three days after the so maybe next week.
So Friday this week you're doing this maybe next Tuesday, Saturday another cheek swab.
Are there supplements that I should have on hand to combat the most common side effects of induced menopause?
Well, again, you know, like we said, the side effects of this induced menopause are from a decrease in your estrogen levels.
And you we can give you a whole bunch of different things that would that would negate that.
But they'd be all estrogen based they'd be things that oh, if you have you know that that a that a person going through natural menopause could take for typically soy.
Isle flavonoids from soy you can't take those you really can't do those so.
The body aches and pain certainly anti-inflammatories can help that like curcumid and Boswellia and you know those kind of things can help that the vaginal dryness you're just going to have to use some creams.
You can't use any progesterone products you can't use anything that's going to be an estrogen stimulator fatigue I would just say adaptogens.
Hot flashes maybe maca root in some of the adaptogens would help with that.
And brain fog definitely the anti-inflammatories the same thing you'll be taking for the aches and body pains.
The flavonoids the curcumid the resveratrol the Boswellia or white middle bark the corset and those are the things that would be good for that.